This is 99% invisible. I'm Sam Greenspan, in For Roman Mars. By now, the story is well known. A man sits in the back seat of a cab, sketching on a note pad as night falls over a crumbling city. He scribbles a letter I, he draws a heart, and then an N, and then a Y, and right away he knows he's got something. This is it, he thinks. This is the campaign. The man was a designer named Milton Glazer. The city was New York, the year 1977. A time and place commemorated by an entire genre of movies
这里是“99%隐形”。我是萨姆·格林斯潘，代罗曼·马尔斯主持。这个故事现在已经广为人知了。随着夜幕降临在一座正在衰败的城市上空，一个男人坐在出租车的后座上，在记事本上画着草图。他草草写下一个字母 I，画了一个心形，接着是一个 N，然后是一个 Y，他立刻知道自己有了灵感。就是这个，他想。这就是这次的宣传活动。这个男人是一位名叫米尔顿·格拉泽的设计师。这座城市是纽约，时间是1977年。那个时间和地点被一整类电影所铭记
dedicated to making it look like a terrifying place to live. Enjoy your typical afternoon in New York City, the most violent town in the world. Let's see the money, man. to live. The city needed a miracle, and it kind of got one in three letters and a simple. I, heart, and why. Telling the story with me is reporter Moog Zadie. Mel and Glazer created the design pro bono for the Empire State Development Corporation. That's the agency that handles tourism for the state of New York.
这些电影致力于将那里描绘成一个令人恐惧的居住地。享受你在纽约市的典型下午吧，这是世界上最暴力的城镇。让我们看看钱，老兄。这座城市需要一个奇迹，而它通过三个字母和一个符号得到了一个奇迹。我，心，还有纽约。和我一起讲述这个故事的是记者穆格·扎迪。梅尔·和·格拉泽为帝国大厦发展公司无偿创作了这个设计。那是负责纽约州旅游业的机构。
So the N.Y. actually refers to all of New York State, not just the city. So I still live in New York, and the sluggo is literally everywhere. Two shirts, hats, towels, plastic bags, oven mitts. For a long time, I didn't even realize that anyone had designed it. I didn't like it or dislike it. It was just part of New York. Of all the pronoun, verb, noun combinations that have ever been turned into a piece of visual design, I love New York is a pretty good one.
所以 N.Y. 实际上指的是整个纽约州，而不仅仅是这座城市。所以我仍然住在纽约，这个标语简直无处不在。T恤、帽子、毛巾、塑料袋、隔热手套。很长一段时间里，我甚至没有意识到这是有人设计出来的。我谈不上喜欢或讨厌它。它只是纽约的一部分。在所有曾被转化为视觉设计的代词、动词、名词组合中，“我爱纽约”算是相当不错的一个。
I'll guess that there's not a single person out there in Listenerland who needs a description. I do not have to tell you that we are talking about a two by two grid, the letters in a tight face with a friendly serif, conjoined by a plump red heart. Both New York City and State have their own official flag, but the heart logo may as well be it. And like any good flag, the logo can inspire a sense of civic pride. I remember the first time I bought an Iheart New York shirt was actually a couple days after 9-11. I was living in Brooklyn and I was on my way to work and saw the towers, you know, exploding.
我猜听众里没有一个人需要对它进行描述。我不用告诉你，我们谈论的是一个二乘二的网格，字母采用紧凑的字体和友好的衬线，由一个饱满的红心连接在一起。纽约市和纽约州都有各自的官方旗帜，但这个心形标志几乎就可以算是了。就像任何一面优秀的旗帜一样，这个标志能激发人们的公民自豪感。我记得我第一次买“我爱纽约”的T恤，其实是在9·11事件发生几天后。我住在布鲁克林，当时正在去上班的路上，看到双子塔，你知道的，爆炸了。
And after that experience, your first thought is how can I show this city that I love it? And of course, the first thing that comes to your mind is this beautiful piece of art that says I heart in New York. And so I went down to Chinatown and I bought a shirt. And I'm pretty sure it was probably not an officially licensed product, but it was $5 and I put it on and I wore it until it smelled bad and it helped me feel better. The thing about the I love NY campaign is that it was so successful that it became part of the built environment.
在经历了那件事之后，你的第一个想法就是：我怎么能向这座城市表达我对它的爱呢？当然，你脑海中浮现的第一件事就是这件美丽的艺术品，上面写着“我爱纽约”。于是我去了唐人街，买了一件T恤。我很确定这可能不是官方授权的产品，但它只要5块钱，我穿上了它，一直穿到它散发出异味，这让我感觉好受了一些。“我爱纽约”宣传活动厉害的地方在于，它太成功了，以至于成为了人工建造环境的一部分。
So people started doing with I love and why, the same thing that humans have always done when encountering something in nature. They started imitating it. My name is Wendy Bryan and I make fleshush internal organs for my company. I have her guts. Wendy runs I Heart Guts out of her home in Tacoma Park, Maryland. She makes these anatomically correct plush dolls of eternal organs. Kidneys, spleen, prostates, you arrive, all with faces full of joy. Wendy started I Heart Guts back in 2005 as a tussure business. The dolls didn't come
于是人们开始对“我爱纽约”做一件事，这也是人类在自然界中遇到某种事物时一贯的做法。他们开始模仿它。我叫温迪·布赖恩，我为我的公司制作毛绒内部器官。我有她的内脏。温迪在马里兰州塔科马帕克的家中经营着“我爱内脏”公司。她制作这些解剖学上准确的内部器官毛绒玩具。肾脏、脾脏、前列腺，应有尽有，而且都带着一张充满喜悦的脸。温迪在2005年创立了“我爱内脏”，最初做的是别的东西。毛绒玩具是
until later. And one shirt was in the style a t-shirt business. The dolls didn't come into later. And once sure it was in the style of I love and why. Which Wendy knew was not totally groundbreaking material? You see, I orange New York on the Tropicana ads, you see t-shirts that say I stomach LA or I spade my cat. Spade like clubs, diamonds, heart spades. Anyway. You see, you know, rip offs of this iconic graphic design absolutely everywhere. Now Wendy is a huge fan of Mill and Glaser. Remember, he's the guy who created I Love New York. He's a genius, he's a brilliant graphic designer. You go on Etsy, there's about a billion different
后来才有的。有一款T恤的风格是T恤业务。毛绒玩具是后来才有的。其中一款T恤的风格是“我爱纽约”的风格。温迪知道这绝对不是什么具有突破性的素材。你看，你在特罗皮卡纳果汁广告里看到过“我橙纽约”，你看到过写着“我胃洛杉矶”或“我给猫绝育”的T恤。这里“Spade”指扑克牌里的黑桃。不管怎样。你看，你知道，这种标志性平面设计的盗版绝对到处都是。现在温迪是米尔顿·格拉泽的超级粉丝。记住，他就是创作了“我爱纽约”的那个人。他是个天才，是个才华横溢的平面设计师。你上Etsy网站看看，大约有十亿种不同的
I hurt in New York rip offs. And nobody ever says that that Milton Glazer is the one who designed this So I wanted to give the man credit where credit is due so on her website She put up a note right next to the t-shirt that called it a quote fun new t based on Milton Glazer's iconic I heart and why design a few months later actually on my birthday in July 2008 it was my birthday I got a season to assist letter that said that I was infringing on the Iheart New York trademark with my design and could I please destroy all the shirts and take them down from the website.
“我爱纽约”的盗版。而且从来没有人说米尔顿·格拉泽才是设计这个的人，所以我想要实事求是地把赞誉归于这位设计师。所以在她的网站上，她在T恤旁边加了一条备注，称其为“一款基于米尔顿·格拉泽标志性的‘我爱纽约’设计的全新趣味T恤”。几个月后，实际上是在2008年7月我的生日那天，那是我的生日，我收到了一封停止侵权警告信，信中说我的设计侵犯了“我爱纽约”的商标权，请我销毁所有T恤并从网站上撤下。
So I was completely freaked out. Iheart New York or really I love New York is intellectual property owned by New York State. You can't just riff on it with your own design and sell it without paying for it. Wendy made some alterations to the merchandise in question, like cutting the design out of the shirt and sewing it back onto another shirt upside down and off-center. The difference between an I Heart Gut shirt and an I Orange New York Tropicana ad is that Tropicana paid for the rights to use it. Most likely, it's hard to get details on specific legal agreements, but for the most part. If you don't pay and you get caught, you get a cease and desist letter. Ignore it, and you've got to loss it on your hands.
所以我当时完全吓坏了。“我爱纽约”，或者说“我我爱纽约”，是纽约州拥有的知识产权。你不能随便拿它来进行即兴创作并出售，而不支付费用。温迪对有争议的商品做了一些修改，比如把设计从T恤上剪下来，然后上下颠倒、偏离中心地缝回到另一件T恤上。“我爱内脏”T恤与“我橙纽约”特罗皮卡纳广告的区别在于，特罗皮卡纳为使用权支付了费用。很有可能是这样的，虽然很难获得具体法律协议的细节，但在大多数情况下。如果你不付钱被抓了，你就会收到一封停止侵权警告信。置之不理的话，你就要惹上官司了。
Though as far as cease and desist letters go, Wendy said this one was... Really sweet. I'm looking at this, you know. Scary cease and desist letter. And how all these like sweet little hearts all over it just scattered all over the page. Ironically, it may have been the shout out to Milton Glazer that got Wendy in trouble, or at least she thinks oh there's really no way to tell. I figured that they probably have legal spider robots that are constantly searching for search terms like Milton Glazer or I Heart New York or I Love New York. We do Google searches and we receive Google alerts.
不过就停止侵权警告信而言，温迪说这封信……真的很温馨。我看着这封，你知道的。吓人的停止侵权警告信。以及所有这些可爱的小心心是如何散落满页的。具有讽刺意味的是，可能正是对米尔顿·格拉泽的致意给温迪惹上了麻烦，或者至少她是这么认为的，其实根本无从知晓。我想他们可能拥有法律蜘蛛机器人，不断搜索诸如“米尔顿·格拉泽”、“我爱纽约”或“我爱纽约”之类的搜索词。我们进行谷歌搜索，然后会收到谷歌快讯。
I mean, I don't think any of this information is very groundbreaking. That's Claire Newman. My name is Claire Newman, and I am an IP licensing executive and legal counsel for CMG Worldwide. And we represent the New York State Department of Economic Development, who is the proprietor and owner of the I Heart and Y trademark.
我的意思是，我认为这些信息都不是什么突破性的内幕。那是克莱·纽曼。我叫克莱·纽曼，我是CMG Worldwide公司的知识产权许可高管兼法律顾问。我们代表纽约州经济发展局，该机构是“我爱纽约”商标的所有者和所有人。
So it's I Heart, not I love. It is actually I love. I can't believe I messed that up. Yeah, it's I love New York. CMG handles intellectual property licensing for, according to their website, celebratory individuals from then, now, and forever. They represent the estates of Emilia Earhart, Malcolm X, Frank Lloyd Wright, and a bunch of other famous dead people. And of course, I love New York, which Claire Newman
所以是“我心”，而不是“我爱”。其实是“我爱”。真不敢相信我把这个弄混了。对，是“我爱纽约”。根据他们的网站，CMG处理来自过去、现在和未来的知名人物的知识产权许可。他们代表埃米莉·厄哈特、马尔科姆·X、弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特以及其他一堆已故名人的遗产管理委员会。当然，还有“我爱纽约”，克莱·纽曼在印第安纳波利斯的办公室就负责代理这个项目
represents from her office in Indianapolis. Claire says about half of her workload is related to licensing I love New York. And she has a number of colleagues who work on it too. Though, to be clear, it wasn't Claire who sent Wendy the cease and desist letter that happened before Claire was working with CMG Her office works with interest inventors like two short manufacturers to license the logo as is or a company can pay to remix the logo Like drop a can of did with eye orange and why Claire looks for infringements on sites like Etsy, Polyvore and Pinterest She says people even report infringements to CMG and sometimes she just stumbles into them.
克莱说，她大约一半的工作量都与“我爱纽约”的授权有关。她还有许多同事也在做这项工作。不过需要明确的是，给温迪寄送停止侵权警告信的并不是克莱，那发生在克莱加入CMG之前。她的办公室与像T恤制造商这样的感兴趣的授权商合作，按原样授权该标志，或者公司可以付费对标志进行重新混编，就像罐装饮料对“我橙纽约”所做的那样。克莱在Etsy、Polyvore和Pinterest等网站上寻找侵权行为。她说人们甚至会向CMG举报侵权行为，有时她也会偶然发现。
Like today, for example, we go ahead and mailing from a cruise line and there was an infringement inside the letter. So it was really coincidental, but you know, we found it. Claire says they have some other methods for searching for infringements that she couldn't talk about. Her job at CMG is about protecting artists, and Claire says the intellectual property is about protecting consumers too. You know, if you buy McDonald's French fries, you know you're getting McDonald's French fries. You're not getting Burger King's French fries.
比如今天，我们在处理一封来自游轮公司的邮件，信件里面就存在侵权行为。所以这真的很巧合，但你知道，我们发现了。克莱说他们还有其他一些搜索侵权行为的方法，但她不能透露。她在CMG的工作是关于保护艺术家的，克莱说知识产权也是为了保护消费者。你知道，如果你买麦当劳薯条，你知道你买到的是麦当劳薯条。你买到的不是汉堡王的薯条。
And so if you started putting different French fries in the McDonald's containers, that trademark... That is the trademark on the container. Would stop indicating the source and origin of those french fries. So, you know, the reason people use trademarks is so that they can go back to trusted brands and trusted labels, and they know they're getting the same standard and the same type of product each time. But if CMG is saying that an IHardGuts t-shirt
因此，如果你开始把不同的薯条放进麦当劳的包装盒里，那个商标……也就是包装盒上的商标。就会停止表明这些薯条的来源和出处。所以，你知道，人们使用商标的原因是他们可以回到值得信赖的品牌和值得信赖的标签，并且他们知道每次都能获得相同的标准和相同类型的产品。但是如果CMG说一件“我爱内脏”T恤
is too close to the Glazer design, I got to wondering how close is too close. I want to play a game. Okay. Basically, I'm just going to give you potential logos that I came up with. Okay, like whether or not I would think that they would be an infringement.
跟格拉泽的设计太像了，我开始琢磨，到底多像才算太像？我想玩个游戏。好的。基本上，我只是会给你看一些我想出来的潜在标志。好的，比如我是否会认为它们构成了侵权。
Yeah. Okay. Let's say you saw I-Sumic, New Jersey. Stomach? Yeah. Um, I mean, I guess I would say yes. I bike Melbourne. I and then a bicycle and then Melbourne. I mean, I guess, I guess, I would have to see it. It's all about like the design and like what the visual is invoking. CMG is vigilant about trademark protection because they have to be. The way the law works is that if you don't defend
好的。假设你看到了“我胃，新泽西”。胃？对。嗯，我的意思是，我想我会说是的。我骑自行车，墨尔本。我，然后一辆自行车，然后是墨尔本。我的意思是，我想，我想，我得先看看。这完全取决于设计以及视觉效果唤起了什么。CMG对商标保护非常警惕，因为他们必须如此。法律的运作方式是，如果你没有充分捍卫
your trademark well enough, you can lose it. Say you think someone is ripping off work that you've trademarked and you try to sue them. If they can prove that you've done a bad job enforcing that trademark in the past, a judge can wind up siding with them. So it's CMG's job to err on the side of thinking that something is an infringement.
你的商标，你可能会失去它。假设你认为有人在盗用你注册了商标的作品，你试图起诉他们。如果他们能证明你过去在执行该商标方面做得不好，法官最终可能会站在他们那边。所以CMG的工作就是宁可倾向于认为某事是侵权。
My position is that everything is an infringement. Wait, why? Because it's my job to protect the mark. Though just because Claire thinks something is an infringement, it doesn't always mean there's a cease and desist letter in the mail from CMG. They send out about 200 I love and why related cease and desists per year. Ironically, one of the people to receive such a letter was Milton Glazer, who, remember, did the original
我的立场是，所有东西都是侵权。等等，为什么？因为保护商标是我的工作。不过，这并不意味着克莱认为某事是侵权，就一定意味着CMG寄出了停止侵权警告信。他们每年大约发出200份与“我爱纽约”相关的停止侵权警告。具有讽刺意味的是，收到这样一封信的人之一就是米尔顿·格拉泽，大家还记得吧，他免费创作了最初的
I love N.Y. designed for free. In 2001, right after 9-11, in an effort to raise money for local New York charities, Glazer created a new modified design that read I love N.Y. more than ever. The state of New York went up apologizing to Glazer and chalked it up to a bureaucratic misunderstanding. Now we can go back and forth about whether or not this indicates that something is broken in trademark law.
“我爱纽约”设计。在2001年，就在9·11事件之后，为了给当地的纽约慈善机构筹集资金，格拉泽创作了一个新的修改版设计，上面写着“我爱纽约，胜过以往”。纽约州最终向格拉泽道歉，并将其归咎于官僚主义的误解。现在我们可以就这是否表明商标法存在漏洞争论不休。
But really, the more interesting question is why does CMG need a whole team of people working on I love and why? I mean, who would have thought that a government ad campaign from the 70s would need to be defended by a team of lawyers from getting stolen and remixed and modified into countless permutations? I don't get it. I just, I totally don't understand. And I have done a lot of things that are persistent in the culture, you know, stuff that
但实际上，更有趣的问题是，为什么CMG需要一整支团队来处理“我爱纽约”？我的意思是，谁会想到70年代的一个政府广告活动，需要由一个律师团队来捍卫，以免其被窃取、重新混编并被修改成无数的变体？我不明白。我就是，我完全不理解。而我做过很多在文化中具有持久影响力的事，你知道的，那些
lasts five years, six years, nothing like this. It doesn't make any sense at all. And you can probably guess who this is. My name is Milton Glazer, I'm a designer, and I spend my day pushing things around until they look good. That's what I do. It was clear from the beginning of our conversation that Milton Glazer is really over talking about I love and why. He's done a ton of other work. He did an iconic Bob Dylan poster and Philip Rothbook covers. He co-founded New York Magazine. And at 84 years old, he's still working.
持续五年、六年的事，没有一件像这样的。这根本说不通。你大概能猜到这是谁。我叫米尔顿·格拉泽，我是一名设计师，我每天都在把各种东西挪来挪去，直到它们看起来不错。这就是我的工作。从我们对话一开始就很明显，米尔顿·格拉泽真的已经厌倦了谈论“我爱纽约”。他做过大量其他作品。他创作过标志性的鲍勃·迪伦海报和菲利普·罗斯的书籍封面。他是《纽约》杂志的联合创始人。而在84岁高龄时，他仍然在工作。
Just recently, he designed an entire visual identity for Brooklyn Brewery. Yet for all his expertise as a designer, even he doesn't understand a success of I love N.Y. I would have thought it would have lost meaning a long time ago. In fact, I thought that it would be a six-month campaign. I thought that in 77, it would probably last six months
就在最近，他为布鲁克林酿酒厂设计了整个视觉识别系统。然而，尽管他拥有作为设计师的专业知识，连他也无法理解“我爱纽约”的成功。我本以为它很久以前就会失去意义。事实上，我以为这只会是一个为期六个月的宣传活动。我以为在77年，它大概会持续六个月
and I'd be done with it. And then when it went through 77 and 78, I thought, well, maybe it has another six month ago. And then it went through 78 and 79. And here we are after so many decades and it's still persists. I can't believe it. I mean there is no doubt that I will go out into the street today and I will see half a dozen versions of it. If you go down to Chinatown, every building, every street, every side of a wall is covered with I love New York.
然后我就不用管它了。接着当它度过了77年和78年，我想，好吧，也许它还能再火六个月。然后它又度过了78年和79年。几十年过去了，我们来到了这里，它依然存在。我简直不敢相信。我的意思是，毫无疑问，我今天走上街头，会看到它的好几个版本。如果你去唐人街，每一栋建筑、每一条街道、每一面墙壁都贴满了“我爱纽约”。
I mean, there are far more I love New York's than dumplings in Chinatown. I mean, why? Why does it persist? I thought maybe it would tell us. I wish I could. Why isn't it tiresome? Everything is tiresome. Maybe I love New York is still around because people just love New York.
我的意思是，“我爱纽约”的数量比唐人街里的水饺还要多。我的意思是，为什么？为什么它能一直存在？我以为也许它能告诉我们答案。我希望我能知道。为什么它不会让人厌烦？什么东西都会让人厌烦的。也许“我爱纽约”至今仍然存在，是因为人们就是爱纽约。
But Milton Glazer thinks that its success has less to do with what the design represents and more with what it is. You know, I think it really is, has more to do with the peculiarity of brain function than it does to any kind of logic. Has something to do with the rigidity of that letter form and the attempt of the grid to contain the erotic nature of the heart. There's something that creates an act of closure and people, minds when they see it, that they won't repeat it. That doesn't bore them. They can look at it a thousand times, a hundred thousand times. And so on, I'm saying, I've had enough.
但米尔顿·格拉泽认为，它的成功与其说与该设计代表的内容有关，不如说与它本身是什么有关。你知道，我认为这实际上与大脑功能的独特性关系更大，而与任何逻辑都没有太大关系。这与这种字母形式的严谨性有关，也与网格试图收敛心形的性爱本质有关。在人们看到它时，某种东西在他们的脑海中创造了一种完形闭合的行为，让他们不会拒绝它。这不会让他们感到厌烦。他们可以看上一千遍，十万遍。以此类推，我说，我已经受够了。
It's a trivial mystery, but maybe not. Maybe it's a profound mystery. Why people are willing to look at certain things over and over and over and over. I mean, this is show of Pierrot, Delifranchesca, the Frick, this week. And I'm going to try to go up there today. I don't think you're a Pierrot.
这是一个微不足道的谜团，但也可能不是。也许这是一个深奥的谜团。为什么人们愿意一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地看某些东西。我的意思是，本周弗里克收藏馆展出了皮耶罗·德拉弗朗切斯卡的画作。我今天打算去那儿看看。我不认为你是个皮耶罗迷。
I love Pierrot. Why am I willing to look at the same pair of feet and the way they cling to the ground in a Pierrot? No other feet at any other painting can make me pay attention for that long. For my whole life I've been looking at that same pair of feet and I'll be looking at it till the day I die with astonishment. Why? Well maybe beyond the I love New York and the phrase and the meaning to the city. They were simply the mystery of form.
我爱皮耶罗。为什么我愿意看着皮耶罗画中同一双脚以及它们紧扣地面的方式？没有任何其他画作中的其他脚能让我关注那么长时间。我一辈子都在看着同一双脚，而且我会带着惊叹一直看到我死去的那一天。为什么？好吧，也许除了“我爱纽约”、这句话以及它对这座城市的意义之外。这里面单纯存在着形式的谜团。
Why does a certain curve and a certain color and a certain contrast hold our attention and why do certain other forms bore us? I don't know. It's a profound mystery. Even still? I think the most wonderful thing about all of this stuff, all of graphics and all of language and all of color is effect. You never get to the reason. Maybe the I love NY design continues to hold our attention because of its infinite capacity for remix that you can substitute literally any part of the equation, the I, the heart,
为什么某个曲线、某个颜色和某个对比能抓住我们的注意力，而其他某些形式却让我们感到厌烦？我不知道。这是一个深奥的谜团。即便如此？我认为所有这些东西中最美妙的事情，所有的图形、所有的语言、所有的颜色，都是效果。你永远找不到原因。也许“我爱纽约”的设计继续吸引着我们的注意力，是因为它具有无限的重新混编能力，你可以字面意思上替换方程式的任何部分，I、心、
the NY, and the cultural reference still comes across. In fact, even New York State is doing this. You can now find the official spin-off logos, I peed the New York, and I beach-balled New York. It is now easier than ever before in human history to take something and change it just enough to make it your own. Imitating and altering and remixing has always been the way that humans engage with the world, but there's a limit here.
NY，而文化共鸣依然能够传达出来。事实上，连纽约州也在这样做。你现在可以找到官方的衍生标志，比如“我尿纽约”和“我沙滩球纽约”。在人类历史上，现在比以往任何时候都更容易拿走某样东西并对其进行恰到好处的修改，使其成为你自己的东西。模仿、改变和重新混编一直是人类与世界互动的方式，但这里有一个限度。
There will always be a baseline need for new ideas to break free of what's been done, and say something truly original, and should you ever fall short of the mark? Somewhere out there is a cease-and-assist letter, waiting to tell you precisely that. Here's a post script. Wendy Bryan from I Heart Guts says that there's a silver lining to getting that cease-and-assist letter from CMG. The language was obviously very frightening, you know, will not be tolerated. Immediate cease and desist, there will be a fee. So it was terrifying, right?
对于新创意来说，永远存在着一种基线需求，即打破既有的做法，说出真正原创的东西，如果你达不到这个标准呢？外面总有一封停止侵权警告信，正等着精确地告诉你这一点。这里有一个后记。来自“我爱内脏”的温迪·布赖恩说，收到CMG的停止侵权警告信也有好的一面。措辞显然非常吓人，你知道的，这是“不容容忍的”。“立即停止侵权，否则将产生费用。”所以这太可怕了，对吧？
And but later on, I actually was able to use the language from the cease to send out my aunt's cease and desist to people who are ripping off my stuff. I'm not the only person who put a happy face on an organ and I don't claim to be, but you have to use different colors and different shapes and you have to come up with your own idea. So again, thanks, Milton. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Mouge Zadie, Roman Mars, and me Sam Greenspan. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, KALW, and San Francisco, and the American
但后来，我实际上能够利用那封停止侵权信中的措辞，向那些盗用我的东西的人发出我自己的停止侵权信。我不是唯一一个在器官上画笑脸的人，我也不自称是，但你必须使用不同的颜色和不同的形状，你必须想出你自己的创意。所以再次感谢，米尔顿。“99%隐形”本周由穆格·扎迪、罗曼·马尔斯和我萨姆·格林斯潘制作。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。特别感谢黛比·米尔曼帮助本期节目顺利完成。如果你喜欢听设计师与其他设计师谈论设计，那你一定会喜欢黛比·米尔曼的“设计之题”播客。你可以在Facebook上找到并关注这个节目，我们所有人都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上。但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括酷炫的图片和链接，并收听“99%隐形”的所有节目，你必须访问 99pi dot org。你必须访问 99pi.org。电台广播结束。
Institute of Architects in San Francisco. Special thanks to Debbie Millman for helping this episode come together. If you like hearing designers talk to other designers about design and you will love Debbie Millman's design matters podcast You can find this show and like the show on Facebook all of us are on Twitter Instagram and Spotify But to find out more about this story including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% invisible You must go to 99pi dot org You must go to 99pi.org. Radio to be out.
为了PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
For PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由PRX制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。